alright yeah yeah chicken watch 2k15
we're gonna find the best rotisserie
chicken and any grocery store chain in
Los Angeles rubric skin dark mean light
me wow factor yo yeah wow factor if you
look at this chicken and you're like wow
bonus points if you can take like the
leg of the wing and flick it and the
meat comes off okay alright do some read
up some chicken back poke your head
through here electro phobia fear of
chickens whoa who could be afraid of
chicken so we're in a mediocre strip
mall there's a Radio Shack here so that
should tell you about how up-to-date
this strip mall is but who knows we're
at the John's marketplace this was made
at 8:30 that was made at 8:30 well
that's it chicken watch 2k15 chicken
watch 2k15 chicken watch 2k15 the
chicken doesn't look very good it dies
to describe this chicken in one word it
would be this get is nightmarish tears
changers it's delicious
I'm very impressed because it looks like
it's gonna be the worst thing also this
was five hours old
so let's chew e no chewy like 1099
John's look straight out of a zombie
apocalypse
yeah this chicken is okay so I'm gonna
give it the wow factor let's go to
Vaughn's let's go to Vaughn's
chickens sperm can survive and a hand up
to 32 days 32 days dear kids are sexual
beat yeah you guys this isn't just Vonda
this is Vaughn's Hollywood oh wow oh
yeah oh yeah dude that's perfect thank
you very much yeah chicken watch 2k15
what's going on there it looks like
somebody grabbed that somebody had some
of it oh my god that skin is amazing I
could eat that chicken skin off there
feel so moist ah how's the dark not as
impressive as everything else has been
it's still early it's still really good
I can't even click it coz it so does
that mean a path yeah it passes it so
tender I pulled both legs out without
trying vods that only gets the wow
factor because of the taste of the
chicken but also because the guy brought
it right out to us was really friendly
yeah and also like dead [ __ ] Ralph's of
7 97 99 let's pack this up and move on
to Albertsons chicken watch 2k15 she can
always in the mood right up to Vaughn
right out to Whole Foods
throw another fact down shame eating
makes a chicken get hot none of these
have timestamps no time no time stamps
well what are we supposed to do I guess
we just guess oh yeah
this one spent some time at the beach to
brown it's very flavorful naturally
shredded it becomes strings well you're
gonna knit a sweater out of this [ __ ]
the flavor is really good the textures
not perfect I did think it looks sexy so
I get one sexy nod to yeah price was
$7.99 let's pack it in Roscoe Oh chicken
no you think in casco chickens can be
cannibalistic peeking helps them not be
cannibals so we're pulling up to Costco
right now which is a membership-only
store and we do not have Costco
membership yeah are you going to Costco
we're making a video about chicken
around the city and we want to try the
one from Costco but we don't have Costco
cards thoughts skin does look crispy
yeah good skin hmm I'll try the white
meat what I expect no so we try the dark
meat it's like standard oh good thing
it's definitely not getting the wow
factor
it has big breasts secretary god see we
were just talking about chickens are
really small right right chicken breasts
are like the size of human breast
it was $4.99 really real to thank my
mother-in-law cuz that was my Christmas
gift Costco membership run away to Whole
Foods I feel like I just now I'm
experiencing a little bit of chicken
fatigue because there's so much so it's
chicken fatigue whole food everyone in
foods in Los Angeles is really hot or
hippies
this chicken is $14 this chicken is $9
yeah they were getting takeout
I got cam boots and my beard it's not
pretty good-looking [ __ ] skin you want
to be called flavor buds yeah we should
be flavor buds either this this white
meat though is ly nothing free-range a
matter this is the best argument so far
it's like together it like has it [ __ ]
together no that's an it's hard that's a
hard flick time I don't think Whole
Foods gets the wow factor
no because you're like you better be
good you're $13.99 I don't know if you
saw the moms in there but they got the
crit sexy mouth sexy old ladies - I'm so
full finger-lickin chicken put it into
your mouth yeah get these kids some
chicken talk about chickens without the
words breasts or [ __ ] before that or
thigh or leg nobody wants a ticket brain
we're going to sprouts have you ever
been to a sprouts
I'm so tired I need to make soup or
chicken watch 2k15 2k I didn't take into
account how all this chicken would make
us feel Wow well the skin doesn't look
right at all
but it's amazing
oh well he said whoa it's the best dark
meat Sam yeah oh it's right there it's
like in the tea there you go wow factor
I mean I'm talking wowie
I would think of chicken what was the
price they're so cheap what if I drink a
little bit of chicken juice hey this is
the best rotisserie chicken I've had so
far I feel like we have a winner hands
down so what do we do to celebrate the
Chucky Cheese is across the street
if you haven't had your chicken yet we
hope one day you find your sprouts and
honestly no matter what year it is in
our hearts it's always chicken watch
2k15 if a rooster is not present in a
flock of hens a hen will often take the
roll stop laying and begin to crow Wow
start producing sperm and grow it in